infinity war was nuts
but this one is going to be your finest
hour we're in the end game you know that
I was wiped out 50% of all living
creatures these are the highest eeks
that the Avengers have ever faced this
is the fight of our lives this is gonna
work Steve I know it is cuz I don't know
what I'm gonna do if it doesn't
everything you think marbles pulled
every single trick out of the bag
they actually saved the best stuff for
this one this is the end of the firework
show the grand finale soit Elia is
insane you just don't know what to
expect
they guarantee you there is no way
anybody could guess what's gonna happen
where's the Avengers we gotta finish
this
tickets on sale now
hi everyone is Charlie there's a whole
bunch of New Avengers endgame footage to
break down I love the way that Robert
Downey jr. throws the gauntlet there
there's no way anyone is ever going to
guess what happens in this movie because
it is so crazy so beyond this clip that
they just dropped they just screamed ten
minutes of footage for press recently so
I'll do a breakdown of those scenes some
of what we've seen before and some of it
was brand new we're only a couple weeks
away from the movie getting here so
we'll do a new round of the IMAX ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
moment from all the trailers so far on
the video the most interesting new thing
and that feature I clipped that they
drop is the footage of Avengers age of
Ultron so when Robert Downey jr. says
you'll never guess what we're gonna do
in this movie because it's so big cuz it
mostly just hyping it up how epic it's
going to be it implies that they're
going to be using every possible
narrative twist that they've teased in
previous movies so you've seen the
quantum realm you've seen the ghost
character face shift through multiple
realities simultaneously you've seen
Doctor Strange travel through other
dimensions talked to big cosmic beings
like Dormammu you've seen him use the
time stone to manipulate time to reverse
time at a localized area and appear
across millions of multiple alternate
timelines which to me is actually a much
more advanced use of the time stone that
we have seen before then just rewinding
time for a group of people or
fast-forwarding it think about the way
they can use all those different
narrative devices based on the footage
that we've seen so far and the behind
the scenes like you see them at the
events of the original Avengers movie
think about how the Russos have been
hyping up on their Twitter and their
social accounts revisiting the original
phase 1 movies if the Russos want you to
pay attention to each one of those films
it means that they're probably going to
be revisiting seminal moments from a lot
of those big movies either in references
or literally revisiting them all of the
behind the scenes that we've seen of
them if the events of the original
Avengers movie where you see ant-man
Iron Man Hulk and Captain America
wearing his original Avengers outfit you
even see Tony Stark with a little shield
emblem on the side of his jacket there
we also see the Benatar ship above Morag
in the last trailer that they dropped so
if they're revisiting Morag for
something related to the Power Stone it
also implies because they're choosing to
use so much Avengers age of Ultron
footage
that will revisit some moment from that
movie related to the mine stone because
not only is the mine stone really
important for the concept of the
Infinity Gauntlet but it was also
critical to the creation of Scarlet
Witch her brother Quicksilver in vision
of the ten minutes of footage that they
showed off to press yesterday it was two
separate clips there were about five
minutes apiece the first one was a brand
new scene of Iron Man and nebula on the
benitar while they're stuck in outer
space at the very beginning of the film
they flashed the Marvel logo then you
started getting those scenes and dear
mr. fantasy by traffic starts playing in
the background twinging so it's kind of
this sad song because obviously they're
stuck in outer space they're trying to
survive Iron Man is recording his sad
message for Pepper pretty sure that he's
gonna die in a couple days he says that
it's been 22 days since the battle on
Titan nebula has helped him heal his
wounds but he's got some crazy infection
that he's telling pepper about during
the message remember he got a couple
really nasty stab wounds from Thanos he
says that their oxygen is getting ready
to run out the following morning so
that's why he's pretty sure that he's
gonna die but they've been slowly trying
to repair the ship
but it's only partially repaired and
something happened to the fuel cells to
wreck them and that's why they're
stranded
he says they managed to eke out two more
days worth of flight time but he doesn't
know how that's going to help them
because they're still quote-unquote
light-years from the nearest 7-eleven
quipping to the last there's another
scene of him and nebula just playing a
game with each other which is probably
one of the coolest moments that you
would never expect to have between those
two characters Iron Man playing a simple
tabletop game with nebula there playing
that game where you fold a piece of
paper into a triangle football and one
person flicks it through the other
person's fingers in the shape of a goal
the clip ends with that scene of him
from the last trailer saying that all
drift off thinking of you from water ran
out four days ago
oxygen ran out tomorrow morning I've
been when I drift off I will dream about
you it's always you very grim very
gruesome but obviously we know that they
make it back because the second clip
that they showed off was unrelated to
the first one it's much later in the
timeline but still very very early in
the film is the same footage that they
screened at CinemaCon it's about a
five-minute clip it's just a longer
version of that argument that you see
Captain Marvel having with Thor when he
summons Stormbreaker
so by this time nebula and Tony have
made it back to earth but for some
reason Tony is not here probably because
he's so shook up and he's convalescing
with pepper off on his own so it winds
up being Captain Marvel Captain America
Black Widow war machine rocket Thor and
Bruce Banner who still has not turned
into the hook yet trying to find out
what they're gonna do next in Captain
Marvel saying why aren't we leaving
right now to go kill thanos she is very
very confident that she can take Thanos
on by herself you know what that means
there's a building her up to get her ass
handed to her by Thanos when they
eventually get there like I said in my
last trailer Warmachine is the one who's
like we usually do things as a team you
know there's a reason why the Avengers
is a team and why we work together it's
not very clear from all this footage how
well Captain Marvel knows Thanos or if
she knows anything about the Infinity
stones or has heard anything about him
because she has been increased girl
space for the last 20 years it sounds
like the Avengers have told her about
everything so she understands the
backstory of all this but based on the
way she's acting she's never run into
any of his minions before or just never
encountered him in battle nebula is the
one that tells them about where his
special farm is they call it quote
unquote the garden now even though the
Russo said the planet that that's on is
called Titan to the Infinity Gauntlet
has a very specific energy signature
that they recorded when he snapped
everyone and they detected the same
energy signature in the area where that
special planet is then that clip ends
with the funny scene of them all
climbing on the back of the benatar with
rocket asking them who here has not been
to space before Captain America war
machine Black Widow all raised their
hands and he tells them you better not
throw up on my spaceship so the end was
the sort of funny moment but it's
basically this scene that you saw
the last trailer here them heading off
the very first time for their first
rematch against Thanos which it sounds
like it's gonna end very very badly for
them something else that makes a little
more sense now too is what Kevin Feige
said about the Captain Marvel movie he
said that they wanted to show her being
really badass in binary at the end of
that but she does have a specific
weakness that they weren't ready to show
you yet which I assume that they're
gonna leave for this first rematch with
Thanos anytime there's a character who
says that they can solve everything at
the very beginning of a three-hour movie
Oh we'll just go get him right now it'll
take 10 seconds we'll kill him it'll be
done we'll bring everyone back it'll be
great that's the cue that something
really really terrible is about to
happen to that character there was also
a really cool clip of the Russos
introducing all this footage here I'll
play a little bit of it here yeah we
just want to say this has been a really
the Marvel Universe up until this point
it's been great getting to know all of
you really looking forward to sitting
down we did we part we poured our heart
and soul that's a lot of our lifeblood
is on the screen
you know we care immensely about these
stories you know these these they're
cultural events and they're very unique
opportunities for filmmakers to compute
the maddox and the storytelling in a way
that
has global reach and so we're seemingly
proud of the film like I said we work
very hard and we're excited to share a
very little with you yeah the cops next
you're gonna see two clips we want to
give you any context where they are but
it will give you a sense of feeling
integrity for the film there's also a
little sizzle to sort of walking through
this point and and then the two clips
are sort of unrelated they'll be like a
little black and then you come up with a
second click okay
yeah but seriously we do we really do
look forward to getting together with
you over the next couple days and
talking about the road that we've all
traveled together with these movies we
probably wants to you out for the
footage because we're actually still
hard at work in the building just the
opposite here finishing the phone so
thank you for being here I hope you
enjoy no big surprise that they're still
working on the movie they'll be working
up on it right to the last day that
they're forced to ship out reels to
theaters all over the world so they can
screen it on time they did say that they
had to speed up the credits a little bit
to keep it down close to three hours
because it was a little bit longer so
don't be surprised if in a couple weeks
by the time we sit down to watch the
movie the runtime has changed again but
it's still gonna be really close to that
three-hour mark here the really big news
you guys may have heard is that they
confirm Angelina Jolie is supposed to be
playing Cersei in the Eternals movie and
they're gonna shoot the shang-chi movie
later this year in Australia so I think
they're still trying to figure out which
movie that they're gonna release at the
end of 2020 we'll get that full phase
four schedule after Avengers end game
comes out sometime maybe they'll wait
till their comic-con panel because they
mostly be promoting spider-man far from
home after endgame comes out but post
all your theories and your reactions in
the comments below let me know if
there's any bonus videos that you want
me to do for Marvel videos obviously
next week Game of Thrones Season eight
starts so I'll be doing episode videos
for that you'll just see as long as you
have alerts enabled for my channel
you'll get all the videos no worries
next week the cast of The Avengers is
also taking over Jimmy Kimmel Oh
every single day so I expect some more
TV spots and footage to drop so no
worries I'll do videos for whatever it
is that they drop but congratulations to
the giveaway winner from my last big
video melissa drop pack please email me
on the about page of my channel so I can
get your contact details click here for
that other brand new Avengers and game
footage that they just dropped and click
here to start getting ready for Game of
Thrones season 8 episode 1 thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]